I
we're here with my master of illusion Oh
cobian VAR you've been closed a couple
of times even as far back as 2003 we're
playing for the championship against
chabala in the last round what do you
think you have to do to get your first
US Champion um to be honest I have no
idea I mean I mean I have to play better
of course you know but sometimes you
just you know yeah it makes a couple of
things you have to perform well we have
to get a little bit lucky so it just got
to be your tournament I think to win it
because in or other person's it's very
difficult to play here and if you win it
you'll get an automatic invite to the
Olympiad team is that right they still
have that rule so I know when you
already won it in a way that was once
that was the reason he wanted to win it
has that thought entered your mind the
automatic qualification absolutely
absolutely i've been coaching the team
last two years but i definitely want to
come back and play an awesome player so
i can contribute a little more yeah
thinking about that OC and you did
something kind of rare amongst players
you let your cat out of the bag and told
everybody who your second was by
inviting him to the players meeting so
was there any kind of psychological ploy
with having a Grand Master Gabriel
targian come to the players a ceremony
yeah I mean it's fine i mean i didn't
want to highly win the room or anything
you know so it's a i think most people
know him that they know that he's a good
friend of mine he came actually in 2009
also with me to this to the US
Championship the first unorganized here
since the Chess Club so yeah I think
it's nothing really to guidance here to
help me and
is a close friend helped me chess wise
also just be a good you know good friend
it's good to have somebody like that
around throughout the long tournament
like this do you like the new format oh
it's just simple round-robin nothing
fancy absolutely this is i think is very
good for Matt I'm very happy about it
because it's just the interview play
against everybody the 11 games you don't
have like a short game six or seven
games when you decided for a tournament
so definitely very happy with the format
ok and should we expect you to see a lot
of French defenses I know that people
prepare for that all the time but at the
same time you know it very well so
what's the thinking there do you are you
ever prepared to play something other
than e6 to surprise your opponent well
I'm feel free comfortable in French
defense you know so i don't think i'm
going to change the whole lot you know
i've been playing it about 20 years
already saw but you never know it might
be some surprise great well good luck
trying to qualify for the US Olympiad
team I know that you've been there many
times the coach but you want to come
back as a player so we wish you well in
the US Champion thank you alright thanks
you